‏Take a moment to check your phone. Make
sure that it is silent. Take a moment to
check your feet and your shoulders. Make
sure that they are exactly in line with
the shoulders and feet of your two
neighbors on either side of you. If we
all do this, the row will be straight in
spite of itself.
[Silence]
الله اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم
[Arabic recitation]
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
لا يحب الله الجهر بالسوء سوء من القول
الا من ظلم
وكان الله سميعا عليما
ان تبدوا خيرا او تخفوه او تعفوا عن سوء
فان الله كان عفوا قديرا
ان الذين يكفرون بالله ورسله ويريدون ان
يفرقوا بين الله ورسله
ويقولون نؤمن ببعض ونكفر ببعض ويريدون ان
يتخذوا بين ذلك سبيلا
اولئك
هم الكافرون حقا
واعتدنا للكافرين عذابا مهينا
والذين امنوا بالله ورسله
ولم يفرقوا بين احد منهم فاولئك
سوف يؤتيهم اجورهم
وكان الله غفورا رحيما
يسالك اهل الكتاب ان تنزل عليهم كتابا من
السماء
فقد سالوا موسى اكبر من ذلك فقالوا ارنا
الله جهره فاخذتهم الصاعقه بظلمهم
ثم اتخذوا العجل من بعد ما جاءتهم
البينات
فعفونا عن ذلك واتينا موسى سلطانا مبينا
ورفعنا فوقهم الطور بميثاقهم
وقلنا لهم ادخلوا الباب سجدا
وقلنا لهم لا تعدوا في السبت واخذنا منهم
ميثاقا غليظا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ورفعنا ورفعنا فوقهم الطور بميثاقهم
ورفعنا فوقهم الطور بميثاقهم
وقلنا لهم ادخلوا الباب سجدا
وقلنا لهم لا تعدوا في السبت واخذنا منهم
ميثاقا
غليظا
فبما نقضهم ميثاقهم وكفرهم بايات الله
وقتلهم الانبياء
بغير حق
وقولهم قلوبنا غلف بل طبع الله عليها
بكفرهم فلا يؤمنون الا قليلا
وبكفرهم وقولهم على مريم مريم بهتانا
عظيما
وقولهم انا قتلنا المسيح ابن مريم رسول
وقولهم انا قتلنا المسيح عيسى ابن مريم
رسول الله
وما قتلوه وما صلبوه ولكن شبه لهم وان
الذين اختلفوا فيه لفي شك منه ما لهم به
من علم الا اتباع الظن
وما قتلوه يقينا
بل رفعه الله اليه
وكان الله عزيزا حكيما
وان من اهل الكتاب الا ليؤمنن
به قبل موته ويوم القيا قيامه
ويوم القيامه يكون عليهم شهيدا
فبظلم من الذين هادوا حرمنا عليهم طيبات
احلت لهم وبصدهم عن سبيل الله كثيرا
واخذهم الربا وقد نهوه عنه واكلهم اموال
الناس بالباطل
واعتدنا للكافرين منهم عذابا مهينا
واعتدنا للكافرين
منهم عذابا مهينا
لكن الراسخون في العلم منهم والمؤمنون
يؤمنون
يؤمنون بما انزل اليك وما انزل من قبلك
والمقيمين
الصلاه
والمؤتون
الزكاه والمؤمنون بالله واليوم الاخر
اولئك
سنؤتيهم اجرا عظيما
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اشهد ان
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
خير
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
‏I got c of quick announcement here
and we need
actually
we have some people sign up for cannci
their names need
firstah
how could miss that my apologies brother
i should have
‏any
other
name
make
you take makeademy
you have some interest pleas come
forward and to brother
টன்
make addum
after 8 for some kids but theশ
anybody
‏moreable
to
want to make are in a proper place not
around the buildings are inside the
building at a safe place so there is a
baby seing againer the baby seating is
free of charge and this facility the
gymnasium opening up that as a
conditionally at this point to see how
it work so there are any children of
that age
‏as
back herefulজ
[Silence]
parent
you knowதி
‏present
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صلي
وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
سوره النساء
سهده
سوره المائده
and
first of all
part of a grust of chapters
that
are all
and
ر
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
العرض الاخيره
before
صلى الله عليه
واث بن الاسق
رضي الله عنه مسند الامام احمد معجم
الطبراني
صلى الله عليه وسلم اوتيت السبع طوال
مكان التوراه
رى
عليه السلام
سهق
سوره ال عمران النساء المائده الانعام
سوره الاعراف
سوره الانفال التوبه
سفى
[Silence]
سوره المائده
اسماء رضي الله عنها
جامع الترمذي
حجه الوداع
صلى الله عليه وسلم حج
was
اسماء
‏was
and
theckle
‏wasenild
الله سبحانه وتعالى
انا سنلقي عليك قولا ثقيلا
صلى الله عليه
‏save it
and not to harm it with the revelation
of this chapter this chapter is a med
chapter but it was revealed in me and it
is one of the last and some scholars say
the last chapter of the quران to beed as
a chapter all at
س
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عرفه
اليوم اكملت لكم دينكم واتممت عليكم نعمتي
لكم الاسلام
I have conuded for you all yourigion
I have perfected my gra upon you all and
I have chosen for you asl to be
yourigion the way that you get close
toانه
and so عائشه صحيح مسلم on
المائده
سهده
was
finossing
eyes
سه المائدهران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
المائده
رضي الله عنهم
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
وان يزيدنا علما نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يملا صدورنا وقلوبنا من حكمه وحيه ومن
حكمه القران العظيم نساله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يجعل القران شافعا مشفعا فينا وانا
يجعل القران حجه علينا والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
صلاه ان شاء الله
تراويح
[Silence]
بسم
‏for
[Silence]
خلاص
‏You want me to get this out?
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
واقف على اصاد الشاك
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
انا اوحينا اليك كما اوحينا الى نوح
والنبيين
من بعده
واوحينا الى ابراهيم واسماعيل واسحاق
ويعقوب والاسباط
والاسباط وعيسى وايوب ويونس وهارون
وسليمان
واتينا داوود زبورا
ورسلا قد قصصناهم عليك من قبل ورسلا لم
نقصصهم عليك
وكلم الله موسى تكليما
رسلا مبشرين ومنذرين
لان يكون للناس على الله حجه بعد الرسل
وكان الله عزيزا حكيما
لكن الله يشهد بما انزل اليك
لكن الله يشهد بما انزل اليك انزله بعلمه
والملائكه
يشهدون
وكفى بالله شهيدا
ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله
ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله قد
ضلوا ضلالا بعيدا
ان الذين كفروا وظلموا لم يكن الله ليغفر
لهم ولا ليهديهم طريقا
الا طريق جهنم خالدين فيها ابدا
وكان ذلك على الله يسيرا
يا ايها يا ايها الناس قد جاءكم
الرسول بالحق من ربكم
فامنوا خيرا لكم وان تكفروا فان لله ما في
السماوات والارض
وكان الله عليما حكيما
يا اهل الكتاب لا تغلوا في دينكم
ولا تقولوا على الله الا الحق
انما المسير عيسى ابن مريم رسول الله
وكلمته القاها الى مريم
وكلمته القاها الى مريم وروح منه فامنوا
بالله ورسله ولا تقولوا ثلاثهوا
خيرا لكم
انما الله اله
واحد سبحانه
سبحانه ان يكون له ولد
له ما في السماوات وما في الارض وكفى
بالله وكيلا
لن يستنكف
المسيح ان يكون عبدا لله ولا الملائكه
المقربون
من يستنكف عن عبادته ويستكبر فسيحشرهم
اليه جميعا
فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فيوفيهم
اجورهم
فيوفيهم اجورهم ويزيدهم
من فضله
واما الذين استن
كفوا واستكبروا فيعذبهم عذابا اليما
ولا يجدون لهم من دون الله وليا
ولا نصيرا
يا ايها الناس قد جاءكم
برهان من ربكم
وانزلنا
اليكم نور نورا مبينا
يهدي به الله من اتبع فاما الذين امنوا
فاما الذين امنوا بالله واعتصموا به
فسيدخلهم
فسيدخلهم في رحمه منه وفضل
ويهديهم اليه
ويهديهم
اليه صراطا مستقيما
يستفتونك قل الله يفتيكم في الكلاله
ان امرؤ ان امرؤ هلك ليس له ولد وله اخت
فلها نصف ما ترك
وهو يرثها ان لم يكن لها ولد
فان كانتا فوق اثنتين فلهما الثلثان مما
ترك
فان كانت اثنتين فلهما الثلثان مما ترك
وان كانوا اخوه رجالا ونساء
فللذكر مثل حظ الانثيين
يبين الله لكم ان تضلوه
والله بكل شيء عليم
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اوفوا بالعقود
احلت لكم بهيمه
الانعام الا ما يتلى عليكم غير محل الصيد
وانتم حرم
ان الله يحكم ما يريد
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تحلوا سعائر الله
لا تحلوا سعائر
الله ولا الشهر الحرام ولا الهدي ولا
القلاء
ولا القلائد
ولا امين
البيت الحرام يبتغون فضلا من ربهم
يبتغون فضلا من ربهم ورضوانا
واذا حللتم فاصطادوا ولا يجرمنكم
ولا يجرمن منكم شنان قوم ان صدوكم عن
المسجد الحرام ان تعتدوا
وتعاونوا على البر والتقوى ولا تعاونوا
على الاثم والعدوان
واتقوا الله ان الله شديد العقاب
حرمت عليكم الميته
والدم ولحم الخنزير وما اهل لغير الله به
والمنخنقه والموقوذه والمترديه
والنطيحه
وما اكل السبع الا ما ذكيتم
الا ما ذكيتم وما ذبح على النصب وان
تستقسموا بالازلام
وان تستقسموا بالازلام ذلكم فسق
اليوم يئس الذين كفروا من دينكم فلا
تخشوهم واخشون
اليوم اكملت لكم دينكم واتممت عليكم نعمتي
ورضيت لكم الاسلام دينا
فمن اضطر في مخمصه غير متجانف لاثق فان
الله
فان الله غفور رحيم
يسالونك ماذا احل لهم
قل احل لكم الطيبات وما علمتم من الجوارح
مكلبين
مكل كذبين تعلمونه
مما علمكم الله
فكلوا مما امسكن عليكم واذكروا اسم الله
عليه واتقوا الله
ان الله سريع الحساب
اليوم احل لكم الطيبات وطعام الذين اوتوا
الكتاب حل لكم وط طعامكم حل لهم والمحصنات
من المؤمنات
والمحصنات من المؤمنات والمحصنات من الذين
اوتوا الكتاب من قبل
والمحصنات من الذين اوتوا الكتاب من قبل
من قبل اذا اتيتموهن
منه والمحصنات
من الذين اوتوا الكتاب من قبلكم اذا
اتيتموهن
اجورهن
محصنين
محصنين غير مسافحين ولا متخذي اخدان
ومن يكفر بالايمان فقد حبط عمله
وهو في الاخره من الخاسرين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا قمتم الى الصلاه
فاغسلوا وجوهكم وايديكم الى المرافق
وانسحوه
وانسحوا برؤوسكم وارجلكم الى الكعبين
وان كنتم جنبا فاطروا
وان كنتم مرضى او على سفر او جاء احد منكم
او جاء احد منكم من الغائط او لامستم
النساء
او لامستم
فلم تجدوا ماء
فتيمموه
فتيمموا صعيدا طيبا
فامسحوه
فامسحوا بوجوهكم وايديكم
منه ما يريد الله ما يريد الله ان يجعل
عليكم من حرج ولكن يريد ليطهركم
ولكن يريد ليطهركم وليتم
نعمته عليكم لعلكم تشكرون
واذكروا نعمه واذكروا نعمته عليكم
واذكروا نعمه الله عليكم وميثاقه الذي
واثقكم
به اذ قلتم سمعنا واطعنا
واتقوا الله ان الله عليم بذات الصدور
يا ايها الذين امنوا كونوا قوامين لله
شهداء
بالقسط
ولا يجرمنكم
شنان قوم على الا تعلوه
اعدلوه هو اقرب للتقوى واتقوا الله
ان الله خبير
بما تعملون
وعد الله الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
منكم
وعد الله الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم
مغفره
واجر عظيم
والذين كفروا وكذبوا باياتنا اولئك اصحاب
الجحيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم
اذ هم قوم ان يبس طوا اليكم ايديهم فكف
ايديهم عنكم
واتقوا الله وعلى الله فليتوكل
المؤمنون
ولقد اخذ الله ميثاق بني اسرائيل
وبعثنا منهم اثني عشر نقيبا
وقال الله اني معكم لئن اقمتم الصلاه
واتيتم الزكاه وامنتم
برسلي
وامنتم
برسلي وعزرتموهم
واقرضتم الله قرضا حسنا لاكفرن
عنكم سيئاتكم
ولادخلنكم
جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار
من كفر بعد ذلك منكم فقد ضل فمن يكفر منكم
فمن كفر بعد ذلك منكم فقد ضل سواء
السبيل
فبما نقضهم ميثاقهم جعلنا قلوبهم قاسيه
جعلناهم
[Arabic recitation]
وجعلنا قلوبهم قاسيه
يحرفون الكلم عن مواضعه ونسوا حظا مما
ذكروا به
ولا تزال تطلع على خائنه
منهم الا قليلا
منهم فاعف عنهم واصفح ان الله يحب
المحسنين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ومن الذين قالوا انا نصارى اخذنا ميثاقهم
فنسوا حظا مما ذكروا به فاغرينا بينهم
العداوه والبغضاء
الى يوم القيامه
وسوف ينبئهم الله يوم القيامه بما كانوا
يصنعون
وسوف ينبئهم الله بما كانوا يصنعون
يا اهل الكتاب قد جاءكم
رسولنا يبين لكم كثيرا
يبين لكم كثيرا مما كنتم تخفون من الكتاب
ويعفوا عن كثير
قد جاءكم
من الله نور وكتاب مبين
يهدي به الله من اتبع رضوانه سبل السلام
ويخرجهم
من الظلمات الى النور باذنه
ويهديهم الى صراط مستقيم
لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله هو المسيح
عيسى ابن مريم قل فمن يملك من الله شيئا
ان اراد ان يهلك المسيح ابن مريم
قل فمن يملك من الله شيئا ان اراد ان يهلك
المسيح ابن مريم وامه ومن في الارض جميعا
ولله ما في السماوات والارض وما بينهما
ولله ملك السماوات والارض وما بينهما يخ
يخلق ما يشاء
والله على كل شيء قدير
وقالت اليهود والنصارى نحن ابناء الله
واحباؤه
قل فلم يعذبكم
بذنوبكم
بل انتم بشر ممن خلق
يغفر لمن يشاء شاء
ويعذب من يشاء
ولله ملك السماوات والارض وما بينهما
واليه المصير
يا اهل الكتاب قد جاءكم رسولنا يبين لكم
على فتره من الرسل ان تقولوه
ان تقولوا ما جاءنا من بشير ولا نذير
فقد جاءكم
بشير ونذير والله على كل شيء قدير
واذ قال موسى لقومه يا قوم اذكروا نعمه
الله عليكم
اذ جعل فيكم انبياء
وجعلكم ملوكا
وجعلكم ملوكا واتاكم ما لم يؤت احدا من
العالمين
يا قوم ادخلوا الارض المقدسه التي كتب
الله لكم
ولا ترتدوا على ادباركم فتنقلبوا
خاسرين
قالوا يا موسى ان فيها قوما الدارين
وانا لن ندخلها حتى يخرجوا منها
فان يخرجوا منها فانا داخل
رجلان من الذين يخافون انعم الله عليهم
ادخلوا عليهم الباب
فاذا دخلتموه فانكم غالبون
وعلى الله فتوكلوا ان كنتم مؤمنون
قالوا يا موسى انا لن ندخلها ما داموا
فيها
فاذهب انت
وربك فقاتلا
انا
هاهنا قاعدون
قال رب اني لا املك الا نفسي واخيه فافرق
بيننا وبين القوم الفاسقين
من اجل ذلك من اجل ذلك
قال فانها محرمه عليهم اربعين سنه يتيهون
في الارض فلا تاس على القوم الفاسقين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
يلا
اه
الحمد
‏You're doing
nothing to worry about. ‏Wish you have
[Silence]
they got
‏Yeah, they started Thursday
I think 29 and 30. That's what I think.
‏ag
[Silence]
اه المايك
دكتور عاص
نعم ان شاء
السلام
[Silence]
احمد
استووا اعتدلوا استووا
استووا
ذا
الله اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واتل عليهم نبا ابني ادم بالحق اذ قربا
قربانا فتقبل من احدهما ولم يتقبل من
الاخر قال لاقتلنك
قال انما يتقبل الله من المتقين
لئن بسطت الي يدك لتقتلني ما انا بباسط
يدي اليك لاقتلك اني اخاف الله رب
العالمين
اني اريد ان تبوء باثمي واثمك فتكون من
اصحاب النار وذلك جزاء الظالمين
فطوعت له نفسه قتل اخيه فقتله فاصبح من
الخاسرين
فبعث بعث الله غرابا يبحث في الارض ليريه
كيف يواري سوءه اخيه قال يا ويلتا اعجزت
ان اكون مثل هذا الغراب فاواري سوءه اخي
فاصبح من النادمين
من اجل ذلك كتبنا على بني اسرائيل
انه من قتل نفسا بغير نفس او فساد في
الارض فكان كانما قتل الناس جميعا
ومن احياها فكانما احيا الناس جميعا
ولقد جاءتهم
رسلنا بالبينات ثم ان كثيرا منهم بعد ذلك
في الارض لمسرفون
انما جزاء الذين يحاربون الله ورسوله ويسع
ون في الارض فسادا ان يقتلوا او يصلبوا او
تقطع ايديهم وارجلهم من خلاف او ينفوا
او ينفوا من الارض ذلك لهم خزي في الدنيا
ولهم في الاخره عذاب عظيم
الا الذين تابوا من قبل ان تقدروا عليهم
فاعلموا ان الله غفور رحيم. يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله وابتغوا اليه الوسيله
وجاهدوا في سبيله لعلكم تفلحون.
ان الذين كفروا لو ان لهم ما في الارض
جميعا ومثله معه ليفتدوا به من عذاب يوم
القيامه ما تقبل منهم ما تقبل منهم ولهم
عذاب اليم
يريدون ان يخرجوا من النار وما هم بخارجين
منها ولهم عذاب مقيم
والسارق والسارقه فقطعوا ايديهما جزاء
بما كسبا نكالا من الله
والله عزيز حكيم
فمن تاب من بعد ظلمه واصلح فان الله يتوب
عليه
ان الله غفور رحيم
الم تعلم ان الله له ملك السماوات والارض
يعذب من يشاء
ويغفر لمن يشاء
والله على كل شيء قدير
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الرسول لا يحزنك الذين يسارعون في
الكفر من الذين قالوا امنا بافواههم ولم
تؤمن قلوبهم
ومن الذين هادوا سماعون للكذب سماعون لقوم
اخرين لم ياتوك
يحرفون الكلم من بعد مواضعه يقولون ان
اوتيتم هذا فخذوه وان لم تؤتوه فاحذروه
ومن يرد الله فتنته فلن تملك له من الله
شيئا اولئك الذين لم يرد الله ان يطهر
قلوبهم لهم في الدنيا خزي ولهم في الاخره
عذاب عظيم
سماعون للكذب اكالون للسحت فان جاؤوك
فاحكم بينهم او اعرض عنهم وان تعرض عنهم
فلن يضروك شيئا وان حكمت فاحكم بينهم
بالقسط ان الله يحب المقسطين
وكيف فيحكمونك وعندهم التوراه فيها حكم
الله
ثم يتولون من بعد ذلك وما اولئك بالمؤمنين
انا انزلنا التوراه فيها هدى ونور
يحكم بها النبيون الذين اسلموا للذين
هادوا والربانيون
والاحبار بما استحفظوا من كتاب الله
وكانوا عليه شهداء
فلا تخشوا الناس واخشوني ولا تشتروا
باياتي ثمنا قليلا ومن لم يحكم بما انزل
الله فاولئك
هم الكافرون
وكتبنا عليهم فيها ان النفس بالنفس والعين
بالعين والانف بالانف والاذن بالاذن والس
سن بالسنين والجروح قصاص
فمن تصدق به فهو كفاره له ومن لم يحكم بما
انزل الله فاولئك
هم الظالمون
وقفينا على اثارهم بعيسى ابن مريم مصدقا
لما بين يديه من التوراه واتيناه الانجيل
فيه هدى ونو
ومصدقا لما بين يديه من التوراه وهدى
وموعظه للمتقين
وليحكم اهل الانجيل بما انزل الله فيه ومن
لم يحكم بما انزل الله فاولئك
هم الفاسقون
وانزلنا اليك الكتاب بالحق مصدق قا لما
بين يديه من الكتاب ومهيمنا عليه
فاحكم بينهم بما انزل الله ولا تتبع
اهواءهم
عما جاءك من الحق لكل جعلنا منكم شرعه
ومنهاجا
ولو شاء الله لجعلكم امه واحده ولكن ليبلو
كم فيما اتاكم فاستبقوا الخيرات
الى الله مرجعكم جميعا فينبئكم بما كنتم
فيه تختلفون
وان احكم بينهم بما انزل الله ولا تتبع
اهواءهم
واحذرهم ان يفتنوك عن بعض ما انزل الله
اليك
فان تولوا فاعلم انما يريد الله ان يصيبهم
ببعض ذنوبهم
وان كثيرا من الناس لفاسقون
افحكم الجاهليه يبغون
ومن احسن من الله حكما لقوم
يوقنون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا اليهود
والنصارى اولياء
بعضهم اولياء بعض ومن يتولهم منكم فانه
انه منهم ان الله لا يهدي القوم الظالمين
فترى الذين في قلوبهم مرض يسارعون فيهم
يقولون نخشى ان تصيبنا دائره
فعسى الله ان ياتي بالفتح او امر من عنده
فيصبحوا على ما اسروا في انفسهم نادمين
ويقول قول الذين امنوا اهؤلاء
الذين اقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم انهم
لمعكم حبطت اعمالهم فاصبحوا خاسرين
يا ايها الذين امنوا من يرتد منكم عن دينه
فسوف ياتي الله بقوم يحبهم ويحبونه
اذله على المؤمنين اعزه على الكافرين
الذين يجاهدون في سبيل الله ولا يخافون
لومتلائم
ذلك فضل الله يؤتيه من يشاء
والله واسع عليم
انما وليكم الله ورسوله والذين امنوا
الذين يقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون الزكاه وهم
راكعون
ومن يتولى الله ورسول رسوله والذين امنوا
فان حزب الله هم الغالبون
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا الذين
اتخذوا دينكم هزوا ولعبا من الذين اوتوا
الكتاب من قبلكم والكفار اولياء
واتقوا الله ان كنتم مؤمنين
واذا ناديتم الى الصلاه اتخذوها هزوا
ولعبا ذلك بانهم قوم لا يعقلون
قل يا اهل الكتاب هل تنقمون منا الا ان
امنا بالله وما انزل الينا وما انزل من
قبل وان اكثركم فاسقون
قل هل انبئكم بشر هل من ذلك مثوبه عند
الله
من لعنه الله وغضب عليه وجعل منهم القرده
والخنازير وعبد الطاغوت
اولئك شر مكانا واضل عن سواء
السبيل
واذا جاؤوكم
قالوا امنا وقد دخلوا بالكفر فر وهم قد
خرجوا به والله اعلم بما كانوا يكتمون
وترى كثيرا منهم يسارعون في الاثم
والعدوان واكلهم السحت لبئس ما كانوا
يعملون
لولا ينهاهم الربانيون والاحبار عن قولهم
الاثم واكلهم السحت لبئس ما كانوا يصنعون
وقالت اليهود يد الله مغلوله
غلت ايديهم والعنوا بما قالوا
بل يداه مبسوطتان
ينفق كيف يشاء
وليزيدن كثيرا منهم ما انزل اليك من ربك
طغيانا وكفرا والقينا بينهم العداوه
والبغضاء
الى يوم القيامه
كلما اوقدوا نارا للحرب اطفاها الله
ويسعون في الارض فسادا والله لا يحب
المفسدين
ولو ان اهل الكتاب امنوا واتقوا لكفرنا
عنهم سيئاتهم ولادخلناهم
جنات النعيم
ولو انهم اقاموا التوراه والانجيل وما
انزل اليهم من ربهم لاكلوا من فوقهم ومن
تحت ارجلهم
منهم امه مقتصده وكثير منهم ساء
ما يعملون
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الرسول بلغ ما انزل اليك من ربك
وان لم تفعل فما بلغت رسالته والله يعصمك
من الناس
ان الله لا يهدي القوم الكافرين
قل يا اهل الكتاب لستم على شيء حتى تقيموا
التوراه والانجيل وما انزل اليكم من ربكم
وليزيدن كثيرا منهم ما انزل اليك من ربك
طغيانا وكفرا فلا تاس على القوم الكافرين
ان الذين امنوا والذين هادوا والصابئون
والنصارى
من امن بالله واليوم
الاخر وعمل صالحا فلا خوف عليهم
فلا خوف عليهم ولا هم يحزنون
لقد اخذنا ميثاق بني اسرائيل
وارسلنا اليهم رسلا
كلما جاءهم رسول بما لا تهوى انفسهم فريقا
كذبوا وفريقا يقتلون
وحسبوا الا تكون فتنه فعموا وصموا ثم تاب
الله عليهم ثموا وصموا كثير منهم والله
بصير بما يعملون
لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله هو المسيح
ابن مريم وقال المسيح يا بني اسرائيل
اعبدوا الله ربي وربكم انه من يشرك بالله
فقد حرم الله عليه الجنه وماواه النار
وما للظالمين من انصار
لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله ثالث ثلاثه
وما من اله الا اله واحد وان لم ينتهوا
عما يقولون ليمس
الذين كفروا منهم عذاب اليم
افلا يتوبون الى الله ويستغفرونه
والله غفور رحيم
من
ما المسيح ابن مريم الا رسول قد خلت من
قبله الرسل وامه صديقه كانا ياكلان الطعام
انظر كيف نبين لهم الايات ثم انظر انا
يؤفكون
قل اتعبدون من دون الله ما لا يملك لكم
ضرا ولا نفعا والله هو السميع العليم
قل يا اهل الكتاب لا تغلوا في دينكم غير
الحق ولا تتبعوا اهواء قوم قد ضلوا قد
ضلوا من قبل واضلوا كثيرا وضلوا عن سواء
السبيل
لعن الذين كفروا من بني اسرائيل على لسان
داوود وعيسى ابن مريم ذلك بما عصوا وكانوا
يعتدون
كانوا لا يتناهون عن منكر فعلوه
لبئس ما كانوا يفعلون
ترى كثيرا منهم يتولون الذين كفروا لبئس
ما قدمت لهم انفسهم ان سخط الله عليهم وفي
العذاب هم خالدون
ولو كانوا يؤمنون بالله والنبي وما انزل
اليهم اتخذوهم اولياء
ولكن كثيرا منهم هم فاسقون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
جزاك الله
احسنت
ان شاء الله
ركعه
تشهد
صلاه ان شاء الله استووا اعتدلوا
الله
اكبر سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك
ولا اله خيرك اعظم بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى سبحان ربي الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى
والذي
اخرج المرعى
فجعل له غثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى
الا ما شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى ثم لا يموت
فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدن الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراهيم وموسى
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم قل يا
ايها الكافرون
لا
اعبد ما تعبدون
ولا
انتم عابدون ما
اعبد
ولا
انا عابد
ما عبدتم
ولا
انتم عابدون ما
اعبد
لكم دينكم ولي دين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن من هديت
وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن
توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
انه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت
ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
اللهم لك الحمد حتى ترضاه ولك الحمد اذا
رضيت
ولك الحمد بعد الرضا ولك الحمد على كل حال
لك الحمد انت نور السماوات والارض لك
الحمد انت قيوم السماوات والارض اللهم صل
على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على ال
ابراهيم
اللهم بارك على محمد
وعلى ال محمد كما باركت على ال ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد مجيد
اللهم اننا
عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو
امائك نواصينا في يدك ماض
فينا حكمك عدل فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم
هو لك سميت به نفسك او انزلته
في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجزاء وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جاهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسيناه
وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم
اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات
وترك المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير
مفتونين
فقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
فاقبضنا
اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
والنصر
على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء
اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من درك الشقاء
وسوء القضاء
وشماته الاعداء
اللهم
اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء
يا حيي يا كريم
يا من يستحيي من عبده اذا ما رفع اليك
اكفه ان تردهما
اذا ما رفع اليك يديه ان تردهما خائبتين
صفرا
ها نحن نرفع اليك اكفنا
ونتبت اليك لما غفرت لنا
لما غفرت لنا ذنوبنا
وكفرت عنا سيئاتنا
اللهم
اننا نعوذ بك ان نشرك بك شيئا
نعوذ بك ان نشرك بك شيئا ونحن نعلم
ونستغفرك لما لا نعلم اللهم ات نفوسنا
تقواها
وزكها انت خير من زكاها
انت وليها
ومولاها
وسلام على المرسلين
الحمد لله رب العالمين
واخر دعوانا
ان الحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
ورحمه الله وبركاته السلام عليكم عباد
[Silence]
من شريفه المسيح الدجال
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
1 is over 1 is
ان شاء